space reality it's more than a linear
path it's a prism
of endless possibility the 23 films of
the MCU that you know we're going to
showcase one little difference in each
episode and see how things change all
our very strength
invites challenge
Challenge insights conflict
conflict
breeds catastrophe
a thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts ladies and gentlemen
Peggy Carter herself Haley Atwell
for my episodes Peggy Carter becomes
captain Carter
we follow her adventure as if she had been the one that took the super serum
it's been almost ten years we were playing
this character you brought the whole
thing to a close in the very end of
Avengers endgame and yet the story
continues it feels like the gift that
keeps on giving but that's also partly
because of the fans they love Peggy they
brought her back
some heroes will rise others will fall
welcome back everyone
is Charlie Marvel has finally released
the footage of Avengers what if they
showed it off at Comic Con and then
again at d23 so this is what that is it
gives you a really good look for what
the series is going to be there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs and we're doing a
new round of the Avengers infinity saga
box set giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
the what if episode that you want them
to do on the video if it wasn't clear
that they're doing 23 episodes total
this is obviously mostly footage for the
marble zombies for the Captain Britain
Captain America episode I'll break that
footage down in a second but they're
doing 23 episodes total one episode for
every single MCU film now Kevin Feige
said so far those 23 films are just from
the infinity saga of films you have all
the stuff that's coming up in Marvel
phase 4 and Marvel phase 5 they'll do
what if episodes for all those movies to
zoom and enhance on all the footage that
they show off when they zoom in on the
logo this is all over the what if logo
itself so you see present-day Nick Fury
then New York City Steve Rogers as they
will be in the Captain Britain Captain
America what if episode more Red Skull
German flair then it rotates to the
other side there's classic art with Thor
and the Avengers more footage from the
Captain Britain episode with Peggy
Carter this very Iron Monger looking
Iron Man's suit is the world war 2 era
Iron Man suit Howard Stark builds for
Steve Rogers because the whole premise
of the Captain America First Avenger
what if episode is what if Peggy Carter
got the Super Soldier Serum instead of
Steve Rogers so obviously they're mostly
focusing on Peggy Carter Hayley Atwell
stuff during this footage but Chris
Evans will come back to voice the role
of Steve Rogers but it'll be a very
different version of the character he'll
still be a little Steve Rogers just
climbing into this giant tank version of
an Iron Man suit the reason why they're
calling her Captain Britain is because
she's British but during the episode
especially after she goes through the
treatment gets the serum they'll call
her captain partner instead of just
calling her Peggy but even though
they're flipping the Captain America
idea and the Super Soldier Serum program
on its head and he's becoming a new
version of Iron Man
back during World War two it seems like
the relationship part of Captain America
First Avenger still holds true that
remains unchanged so they're still with
each other maybe they ride off into the
sunset or she winds up in the ice you
get a little more Thor even though most
of these are featuring Captain America
stuff probably because those are the
first couple of episodes I believe the
captain Britain Captain America episode
will be the first one even though Iron
Man 1 is technically the first MCU film
I think they're still trying to figure
out how they're going to get Robert Downey jr. to come back and voice the character
for his animated episodes but I'm pretty
sure that he will do it we see modern
Iron Man's armor on one side then more
red skull then Steve Rogers getting the
Super Soldier Serum like he did
originally
then Hawkeye in present-day this person
with a long flowing robe in the cane
kind of seems like the watcher but the
watcher isn't known for using a cane
it's just that there aren't that many
people in the Marvel Universe that wear
robes like this aside from the watcher
and it doesn't look anything like the
clothes the Doctor Strange wears this
rendering of the watcher with all this
cosmic stuff behind him it's just the
way he perceives the universe is not
meant to represent his actual body they
do have physical bodies they are trapped
in a form and he usually lives on the
moon and watches what happens on planet
earth to the Avengers from that vantage
point we get more footage of Peggy
Carter coming out of the Super Soldier
device after getting the serum more
blurry Captain America art while The
Watcher talks about time not being a
linear path so they're sort of
transitioning to the what-if part of the
what-if episodes then we get footage of
black panther T'Challa but it's him as
star-lord during the events of the first
guardians of the galaxy movie and he's
going to steal the Power Stone fun fact
it was actually just revealed that
Chadwick Boseman Black Panther himself
auditioned for the role of Drax during
the first guardians of the galaxy movie
obviously did not get that part but they
said that later it helped when they were
trying to think of people to cast his
Black Panther because they'd already met
with him on other roles so maybe that's
why they chose to do the guardians of
the galaxy theme for his Black Panther
episode his costume looks like a
wakandan variant of star-lords costumes
so it sounds like it might be a scenario
where ego the Living Planet instead of
going to America and mating with Peter
Quill's mother went to Wakanda and mated
with Black Panthers mother giving birth
to T'Challa who's half celestial Peter
quill wasn't that young when he was
taken by yondu and the Ravagers he had
some culture that's how he understood
the concept of mixtapes and they used
that during the movie so it would
explain how Black Panther knows about
wakandan culture and integrates that
with his Ravager uniform these are just
the showrunners they're working on all
the episodes but they've been working on
it for a while now up to this point
which is why they have footage to
actually show off during Comic Con at
d23 this summer this is a much better
look at Steve Rogers old-school Ironman
armor which is basically a flying tank
and this is Peggy Carter's concept art
of her Captain Britain uniform so
obviously she's probably going to have a
couple different variants of it the same
way they had a couple different versions
of the Captain America suit and it
evolved through the course of that movie
this is our first look at the Marvel
Zombies episode not to be confused with
the Captain Britain episode but zombie
Captain America pretty self-explanatory
they haven't explained how they're going
to introduce them if it's going to be a
twist on comic book Marvel Zombies but
in the comics the way they explain is
that all the zombies came from an
alternate reality they do have some
cognitive function so zombie Reed
Richards was able to help port them from
their universe to our 6-1-6 universe I
don't need to give you a spoiler warning
to say that things do not end well in
the Marvel Zombies storyline for our
universe this scene of Captain Britain
Peggy is just doing the exact same type
of landing the Captain America did
during Winter Soldier where she spins
through the air and lands with the
shield down jamming it into the ground
she seems like she's just taking down a
German convoy in the middle of the
street it's just made to give you a
sense for how much stronger she gets and
they do talk about it like she's had the
same military training that Steve Rogers
got so when they start out there's a lot
of parity between how good they are the
difference between that and modern-day
Captain America during the events of the
Avengers films and like Avengers end
game is that you have a version of
Captain America who just had many many
years in present days studying modern
martial arts and fighting techniques you
get a much cooler scene of her version
of Steve Rogers in a wide shot of the
new Iron Man suit joining her during
battle with the Howling Commandos behind
them I believe a lot of those actors
will be coming back to voice their roles
- then you had the watcher talking about
heroes falling and we get our Marvel
Zombies teaser with zombie Captain
America in Winter Soldier sort of
reenacting the Winter Soldier scene were
kept throws a shield at Bucky but he
catches it and throws it right back at
him that was actually in the very first
winter
soldier teaser trailer just because it
was such a badass shot and if you
noticed Bucky is wearing his suit from
Avengers end game so it's implied that
this is taking place after the events of
Avengers endgame maybe that'll have
something to do with the plot of Marvel
Zombies maybe there's some sort of tear
in the multiverse because of what Thanos
does snapping the gauntlets so many
times they haven't revealed what the
theme of each what-if episode is going
to be for each MCU movie but you could
probably guess what some of the bigger
twists are like what would happen if
Ultron were to be successful and did
take over the planet using the mine
stone and entered visions body like he
wanted to you know know a lot of you are
wondering about Spider Man yes they will
be doing two episodes for both
spider-man film spider-man homecoming in
spider-man far from home the reason why
Marvel can do this without getting
approval from Sony is because Marvel has
the rights to do animated Spiderman TV
shows that are under 42 minutes long
Sony still has the live-action TV rights
which is why Sony just said they're
doing five separate spider-man spider
verse live-action TV shows so let me
know in the comments which what-if
episode are you most excited to see we
got the Black Widow trailer coming in a
couple weeks there's a bunch of other
footage that they drop so I'll do videos
for all the other teasers and trailers
for the Marvel phase 4 stuff in the next
couple of days while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 1 video
and click here for my Mandalorian
episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!